Tick tock, time to rock. Good evening,
good morning, good afternoon to everyone
who's watching from all over the world.
It's your friendly neighborhood
philosopher here, Dwood Wood. And with
me now, got a few guests. We got uh
Raymond Ibraim and we got Jai and Doc.
Uh Jai and Doc are with me pretty
frequently. Uh Raymond has been with I
think one I think we did one live stream
together. Is that was that it? No. Yeah.
Okay. One. Um yeah. So, um, did a live
stream, I think that was last year with
Raymond Ibrahim, but he is your, uh,
friendly neighborhood historian, but why
don't you go ahead and, uh, tell
everyone about yourself in case they're
uh, in case they're not familiar with
you.
Sure. Yeah, I'm kind of like a dinosaur
guy that's been around for a long time,
but back back before YouTube when people
read and wrote and that was the main
medium, so that's what I've been uh
doing for almost 20 years. Um, you know,
my first article for the LA LA Times
came out in 2005. I was just reminded,
so 20 years, and it was about Islam. Uh,
but basically, long story short, I've
studied it histo in in the academic
setting. I have a master's degree in
history dealing with Islam and the
interaction between Islam and
Christendom. And I worked at the Library
of Congress, went to Georgetown
University, Catholic University, again,
took many classes about Islam. Um, know
the languages. That's what I and then I
worked at the Library of Congress where
I actually dealt with all these
languages. Um, and if and actually uh
the hadith we're going to talk about the
first time I saw it was at the Library
of Congress where an Arab speaker that I
knew when he knew I was getting into
this field of Islam and I had I was my
first book came out in 2007. So I was at
the Library of Congress about al-Qaeda
and he was like, "Hey, come here. Let me
show you something." And I distinctly
remember him pulling out Musid bin Hul
Ahmed bin Hul and saying, "Hey, read
this." And I read it and it's what we're
going to talk about. And I just remember
thinking like, "Are you serious?" And I
I thought to myself, "Yeah, this is a
joke." But well, it wasn't. Um anyway,
that's a little side note there. And uh
uh other than that, I've been also
writing a lot of books. Um most of my
all I've been doing has been writing in
the last almost 20 years books. and some
are pretty uh wellreceived. The last
two, Sword and Scimitar, Defenders of
the West, which deal with the history of
Christianity and Islam. And uh now I've
now finally realized that everyone wants
to watch videos, which is kind of cool
because it's uh pretty easy to because I
already have the knowledge. So now I'm
trying to do this sort of thing. And you
know, kudos to you, David, for actually,
you know, being the trailblazer of this
sort of thing uh videos. And so, yeah,
I'm trying to bring this message to all
the millennials and the Gen Z types who
don't have time to read and that's uh
that's a good approach. So, you uh spent
years doing all your research uh
compiling all the information and now
sharing it on YouTube. So, everyone
who's watching uh the link to Raymond's
YouTube channels in the description as
well as to his recent video on this
topic. Now, I've uh I've heard about
this for a long time, mostly from Arabic
speakaking Christians who tell me, "Hey,
you need to check this out." Or, "David,
what are your thoughts on uh they'll
either say these men or they'll say the
jin riding Muhammad all night long and
so on." And uh for me, it's always it's
always uh everything is about
timing. Everything is about timing. Like
something will happen and I just won't
be interested in it. and all of a sudden
something will happen. I'm like, "All
right, now's the right time. Now's the
right time to go with this." And seeing
your video is like, "You know what? This
is a good time for this. This is a
really good time for uh to popularize
this story among English speakers
because the the Arab the Arab-
speakaking Christians know about this
story. Um, let's go ahead and watch this
video. Um, I'm fine playing it all the
way through, but if you want to uh uh
pause and jump in at any point or talk
about something, uh, just let me know
and I can pause it.
Go ahead, play through and then if I
have any additions, I'll do it later.
All right, so let's go ahead and watch
the video here at the beginning, ladies
and gentlemen. It's pretty short video,
very sharable. The link is in the
description box. You should be sharing
this stuff everywhere.
And let's go. Okay, I recently watched a
hilarious debate on an Arabic religious
program that once again reminded me of
the importance of the hadith. So, let's
have a quick discussion about it.
Cherished by Muslims for containing the
instructive and edifying words and deeds
of their beloved prophet Muhammad. The
hadith also serves as one of the most
potent weapons, one of the most potent
pmics against Islam. It is in fact a
double-edged sword. So, let's look into
it. Before unpacking this strange irony,
however, a little relevant background.
In an earlier video, I said that
although those Western people who insist
that Muhammad never existed dismiss the
hadith as forgeries, the hadith actually
do lend credence to the existence of an
Arabian prophet, though indirectly. Why
did I say this? Because if they were
later forgeries meant to create a sacred
foundational story for Islam centering
around around a noble and righteous
prophet, why do so many of them present
Muhammad in a very unflattering light?
As does the hadith we will soon be
examining. The most uh did want to pause
there. pause very quickly on that
because uh that's a similar argument to
what I use. I've debated Robert Spencer
and J. Smith on the existence of
Muhammad. Robert Spencer and J. Smith
both believe that Muhammad didn't exist
or if he did exist, he's so completely
unrecognizable historically, that he
bears almost no connection with the
Muhammad we read about in the sources.
But you're looking at this in a similar
way to what I argued, what I argued in
debating them. I have to acknowledge you
got a we've got a problem that you know
we're lacking very early material and so
on. So we have to rely on
um basically historical principles to
try and discover reliable information.
But that's very similar to what what
I've always uh what I've been arguing is
that if you could invent anyone, if you
could make up anything you wanted, you
can make up the guy who's absolutely
perfect for whatever you're trying to
accomplish. But the Muslim
sources are filled with material that I
can't imagine
making making up for any any relevant
purpose. Like the stories of the satanic
verses, Muhammad um delivering
revelations from the devil, Muhammad
being a victim of black magic, Muhammad
being covered in semen and so on and
Aisha having to come up with 27
different ways of trying to clean it off
him and so on. But then this story as
well. So you're a fan of applying the
principle of embarrassment that
basically histori works in law courts
too. If someone admits something in
court that while testifying that would
be embarrassing that would actually hurt
his case. They actually people look at
that and say I trust this person more
for sharing this because it actually
could could hurt him. But historians
look at things and it's basically you
know three categories. it's uh it helps
you, it hurts you, or it's neutral. And
when a Muslim's examining the history of
Muhammad, embarrassing material, they'll
say, "Oh, this this couldn't have been
true. This this must have been made up
because it's so embarrassing, like the
satanic verses." But historians look at
that and they go, "Oh, this is
embarrassing." So, it doesn't seem like
something someone would have made up.
And if someone did make it up, doesn't
look like something that Muslims would
have just shared and spread around like
crazy. And so the best explanation for
why we have this really embarrassing
material is that it happened and early
on they knew it happened and they were
just and they were just recording it. So
you're you're a Yeah. Mhm. Yeah. No, no,
no. You're absolutely right. And um and
that is my position. And I would amplify
it a little bit more by saying first of
all, you know, having really listened to
a lot of the people who argue against
the hadith, I got to tell you that um
they go way overboard. Okay, for
starters, it's become almost axiomatic
listening to some people that the hadith
um you know aren't compiled until 250 or
300 years after Muhammad. I mean, I hear
a lot of people say that actually the
earliest hadith is about 130 years after
Muhammad's death. And that's the Mata by
Melik, okay? And he's one of he used to
be one of the earliest jurists. Um okay,
so we have about 130 years after
Muhammad's death, we have the Hadith.
Okay? The other thing that you have to
keep in mind is that these a lot of
people think when they hear these crazy
warped hadith such as the one we're
going to discuss that oh yeah all these
crazy people are running around saying
whatever they want for the whatever
agenda they have and it's not like that.
Okay, these hadith compilers that we're
talking about, the six canonical ones,
and as well as the one we're going to
talk about, which is uh uh Ahmed bin
Hul, who's actually he's known as the
unofficial seventh Sah. And in fact, the
the hadith we're going to talk about is
considered Sah. We'll get into that. But
anyway, um these guys were fanatical
Muslims who loved Muhammad. bin Hamul,
the guy we're talking about who recorded
the hadith in question, refused to eat a
watermelon because he could not find a
hadith of Muhammad eating a watermelon.
So my point is these were very pious um
you know Muslims who were also very
simple men. In other words, they they
all they cared about is transmitting the
correct hadith and if it looked weird or
warped or perverted, they didn't care.
Their job was to just record it. And I
believe that's why you have all these
weird hadith uh as you were indicating.
Um and and like you said, why would
people make this up? But but but like I
said, a lot of people just don't even
understand the nature of the hadith.
They think it's just like running around
and anyone can say anything and anyone
can believe anything. It's not like
that. It's actually pretty rigorous. And
also let's keep in mind um you know the
the whole logic of the hadith the why
the reason it's written so much later
whether it's 130 years like you know 130
years and on 200 250 years etc is
because the Arabs weren't illiterate
people we know that but illiterate
people maintain oral traditions we've
seen that in the Americas okay the
native Americans and you know when
people maintain or illiterate people
have really remarkable memories Okay,
let's think about ourselves before we
got iPhones where everything's recorded.
I remember as a kid I I mean I still
remember my phone number when I was 9
years old. I remember my address. I
remember everything. Today I don't
remember my phone number. I actually
have to look it up to be honest with
you. All right. So my point is when you
when you're an illiterate people, the
oral testimony is so important and
people have such a sharp memory that
it's really a hard it's not what we
think, you know, oh yeah, whatever.
So my point is I'm not trying to say
that the the hadith is authentic. I'm
just trying to say that that very
argument itself that everyone has just
jumped on board with and kind of like
poo pooed the hadith. Oh yeah, we can
ignore it. I don't do that. I really
think the hadith there's definitely some
kernels of truth in it. Especially with
what we're talking about this sort of uh
embarrassing stuff for the reasons that
I just described. um you know these guys
were serious pious devotees of Muhammad
and they didn't even they they didn't
have the critical thinking capacity to
say oh this makes them look bad all they
wanted to do is the isnad correct uh the
isnad is the chain of narration is this
person authentic or not uh in regards to
narration that's it and they put it in
and that's why when you look at it it's
so full of very unflattering things like
what we're going to talk about um so
that's just like my little preamble
about the hadith which amongst the
Muhammad doesn't exist people is not
even worth talking about. It has to be
just like ignored completely. And even
scholars uh actual real scholars take
the hadith seriously. Sort of like I'm
saying, including Patricia Cron, the one
who actually uh went who really started
this Muhammad didn't exist mo movement
until about 2008 when she wrote an
article where she said she emphatically
believes Muhammad existed. Um so anyway,
a little pre a little preface there for
you. Mhm. So, in your face, Robert
Spencer and Jay Smith, you heard it
here. Uh, and, uh, yeah, I just wanted
to verify, um, for all you young people
who cannot conceive of a situation where
you would, uh, have to memorize lots of
numbers, uh, back when, back when
Raymond and I were kids, you didn't just
remember your own phone number. You had
all your family uh, members phone
numbers memorized. All your friends, you
knew like 20 or 30 or 40 phone numbers
back then. And it was just totally
normal. you had to dial up on the phone
all your friends and so on. So what that
means is there are uh you use your brain
in certain ways and your brain gets used
to it and your brain adapts well. And so
oral cultures would be significantly
better at uh sharing information,
passing on information um than we are.
And
so this story, ladies and gentlemen,
can't just toss it aside. But uh back to
the video. Oh wait, hang on. Got two
rude two rude comments here real quick.
Uh Kuman now always on time. They're
referring to AP who's historically
always late, but as soon as he became uh
soon as he became a Christian, he's
always on time. Um, and they're using
this to attack Protestants everywhere
saying Protestant now always late. Draw
your own conclusion. Very, very rude.
Very rude. And then this one, too. All
these years AP got blamed for being
late, but turns out it was delay wood
with the daily weight all this time. Now
they're calling me Delay Wood. Uh,
extremely extremely rude. I'll probably
ban these guys later. Anyway, back to
this video. Common rebuttal to this
observation appearing in the comment
section of that video. See I do read
them went as follows. Sir, you need to
understand things that seem strange to
us moderns were normal among the Arabs
of the time. No, I do understand that.
Really, I do. And even in that previous
video had given as an example of the
notorious alith whereby Muhammad told a
woman to breastfeed a man. That is to
thrust her breast in a grown man's mouth
as a way of making him her son.
[Music]
Brother, what's
that? Considering the conservative,
patriarchic and hyper tribalism of 7th
century Arabia, trust me when I say that
Muhammad was introducing a radical and
shocking idea even then, which brings me
to my point how the Arabic program I
recently watched validated these two
points. first that the bizarre and
unflattering accounts of Muhammad
contained in the hadith contradict the
idea that the hadith is a later forgery
meant to give Islam a noble foundational
story revolving around a pious and
upright prophet and much more
importantly second that the hadith
because it does capture the essence of
Muhammad remains the chief weapon
against Islam. Now, the debate I watched
centered around a hadith that though
long hidden first started reaching the
general populace of the Arabic speaking
world via satellite programs. I'd say
around 2015ish or so, I first wrote an
article about it in 2022. Link in
description. This odd hadith which I'm
about to narrate appears in several
hadith collections including the highly
esteemed musid of nah founder of one of
Islam's four schools of laws or medib as
well as in many other wellrespected
Islamic texts all of which are being
taught in alazar and all of which I have
listed volume and page numbers in the
description of this video. The hadith
which is narrated by Abdullahbin Masoud,
a companion of the prophet and one of
Islam's most reliable and trustworthy
transmitters of a hadith goes as
follows. Brace yourself. Abdullah begins
by telling us that Muhammad called on
him to accompany him on a trip into the
desert. When they reached a certain
place and night had fallen, Muhammad
made a line in the sand, most likely a
circle, and told Abdullah, quote, "Stay
behind this line and do not cross it,
for if you do, you will die." Muhammad
then left his startled companion and
walked into the desert night about the
distance of a hurled stone, says
Abdullah. Before long, our narrator saw
a group of men. He does not specify how
many who quote appeared to be alut. He
describes them as quote tall, lean, and
naked. Other Islamic sources say the Zut
were a black-skinned people, and we'll
get into that later. After describing
them, Abdullah goes on, and here's the
problematic part, to say, quote, "They
went to and began to ride the prophet of
Allah." Literally, that's what the
Arabic says. These tall, black, naked
men rode Muhammad, the Arabic word
yakabun, which I will presently discuss,
can also be translated as mounted. And
they did this all night long, says
Abdullah. during which time they would
also come and circle around and try to
reach him, but they were prevented
apparently from the line of protection
Muhammad had drawn in the sand for his
companion. Abdullah concludes his
narration, quote, I was extremely
terrified by them, so I sat down. With
the coming of dawn, they began to
depart. Then the prophet of Allah
returned slowly and in pain from that
which they did while riding him.
According to another narration found in
several Islamic text, did want to point
out someone uh made an interesting
observation in the uh comments when I
was uh asking whether people thought
this was uh consensual or
non-consensual. They pointed out that it
seems consensual and that it's
understood like anyone behind this line
is off limits for uh for the
festivities. always uh always a possible
interpretation including no it's very
clear that it was a it was a pre-planned
rendevous because he came and told him
hey stay there I'm going to go do
something over there and I'll be back
you know and uh and all the just so you
know all the guys who are coming they
all understand that's the uh that's the
uh line where you get to watch but right
right right by alahe Muhammad complained
to Abdullah that quote they wounded me
all night long, at which point the
prophet proceeds to lay his head and
fall asleep in Abdullah's lap. Needless
to say, the highly unflattering
implications of this hadith are clear.
But it becomes even more scandalous once
one brings in what several other Islamic
reference books and histories say. For
starters, who are these alut, these
naked men who wrote Muhammad all night
long? According to Islam's written
records, they were a migrant people from
India or modern-day Pakistan. described
in the sources as very tall, very
dark-skinned, very lean, strong and
hardy and often used for labor intensive
work. In early Arabic ethnographies and
literary works, alz are also depicted as
being very sexual and veriral with very
large penises. In fact, according to one
Arabic source by quote, "The penis of
alz never weakens," meaning their large
fallaces never go limp and are ever
ready. I I have to point out um I have
received lots of
comments from Indians and Pakistanis uh
cheering for this um
so have I right they're right about us
I've so anyway I'm sorry for the
couplang but this is what the Islamic
texts say verbatim now let's talk about
the Arabic word translated as ride as in
alzot O the prophet. Not only does it
have the same exact meaning in English
as in to ride a horse, for example, but
it carries the same slang meaning as in
copulating with a woman. In fact,
several Islamic sources use it literally
to mean sex. For example, while
commenting on the famous hadith also in
Muslimn where Muhammad says, quote,
"Women, dogs, and donkeys cancel a man's
prayer." Al Kuri, one of Islam's most
celebrated commentators of the Quran,
elaborates by saying, quote, "A woman
may be compared to a cow, horse, or
camel, for all are ridden."
I have to point out you could say a
woman may be compared to a a horse, a
cow, a camel, or Muhammad and that all
are ridden. Just wanted to he could have
added that. He could have added that. Um
yeah, it's also interesting to note that
when Al Zut begins circling and trying
to reach our terrified narrator
Abdullah, his first instinct was to sit
down. Was he trying to hide and protect
that one part of his body which these
naked men were apparently trying to
access, that is his bottom, by sitting
down? Again, as I think you can see,
this hadith is scandalous. Not the sort
of thing you'd expect people who want to
fabricate an honorable prophet would
make up. Nor, I can assure you, was such
a deed done hidden in the desert night
deemed normal or acceptable among the
Arabs of Muhammad's time. Now, during
the debates I've watched over this
hadith, others, including many former
Muslims, regularly make even more
troubling connections. For example, they
cite the well-known hadith where
Muhammad is asked, quote, "Will the
people of paradise have sex?" And his
answer, quote, "Yes, with a vagina that
never tires and a penis that never
weakens." Hm. The phrase, "A penis that
never weakens," is identical to the
aforementioned description of Alz's
genitalia, suggesting, as many former
Muslims are quick to point out, that
Muhammad so enjoyed his night with these
naked black men that he went on to
secretly enshrine its most notable
aspect, powerful penises that never
weaken or slacken as a characterization
of paradise and possibly as an inside
joke with himself.
To sum up, based on numerous Islamic
texts, especially Musnel and
Elubsir and several other historical and
ethnographical texts. Again, see this
video's description for references. How
this hadith is understood, especially by
ex-Muslims who cite it as cause for
their apostasy, is as follows. And
before I proceed, please note that the
following summary is not based on my
thoughts or words, but rather the words
of first, as we saw, wellrespected
Muslim texts. And second, those who use
this hadith as a palemic against Islam.
I'm trying to give you an idea of what
is being said and how this hadith is
being presented in these debates that
often flare out between Muslims. All
right, here we go. Muhammad took his
close companion Abdullah into the desert
at night. He warned him to wait behind a
line and went off at a distance,
apparently for a pre-planned rendevu.
Before long, Abdullah saw several naked
men from the people of Elzut appear,
described in the sources as tall, lean,
veriral, and with large penises. These
men then took turns riding or mounting
the prophet all night long. They also
tried to reach him, but Abdullah
immediately sat down, apparently to
protect that one part of his body they
were trying to access. As the sun rose,
these naked men began to depart, even as
Muhammad returned in pain, limping
towards Abdullah and saying how Al Zut
had injured him. He then lays in his
companion's lap and falls asleep.
Finally, as a reflection of what
Muhammad thought of that night, he went
on to enshrine it as an aspect of
paradise where the quote penis never
weakens end quote. Okay, that's what's
being said and what loud shouting
matches take place over. I've personally
watched several satellite Arabic
language shows where Muslims call in and
ask an expert sheh about this hadith.
Typical responses are that one,
alz two, this occurred during Muhammad's
famous meeting with the jin, known in
Islamic tradition as the night of the
jin when the prophet recited the Quran
to them. And three, it's known that
Abdullah bin Masoud was not present with
Muhammad during the night of the jin. So
therefore, this hadith must be weak and
likely fabricated. Such are the
responses against this hadith. As we
have seen, however, and as those who use
this hadith as a pmic against Islam
point out, the earliest references to al
depict them as humans. And dismissing
the hadith as weak on the claim that
Abdullah was not present for the night
of the jin is itself very weak since the
night in question had nothing to do with
the jin. Meaning there is no reason to
doubt the words of Abdullah, a chief and
highly trusted transmitter of hadith. By
the way, I decided to ask chat GBT what
it thought were innocent and non-loaded
questions. And as might be expected, it
answered me honestly enough. First, I
asked it whether alz were humans or jin.
To which it responded, quote, "In Muslim
historical sources, the zut were
consistently described as humans, not
jin. They were portrayed as a real
ethnic group, most often associated with
India or sind, modern-day Pakistan, and
as a migrant labor or military class.
They are also described as a rebellious
and militarily capable people. I then
asked chat GBT to give me a physical
description of alz based on early Arabic
sources and it said quote in literary
and anecdotal texts they are grouped
together with other southern or
dark-kinned people all of whom have the
following traits sexual potency
prominent genitalia and associations
with physical strength and verility.
Anyway, so there you have it. Here is a
perfect example of why the hadith should
not be so quickly dismissed as later
forgeries meant to present an honorable
prophet. And here is a perfect example
of how the hadith is being used as a
powerful weapon against
Islam. All right, that was one of the
most Islamophobic things I've ever seen
in my entire life. Um, very, very rude.
Uh, all right, Raymond. Now, uh before
we were talking, uh you were saying you
had some additional follow-up thoughts
on um
Yeah. on the issue on the night in
question. Yeah.
Yeah. So, I've looked at um I've already
been So, like I said, this is this has
been known amongst Muslims and
especially Christian apologists of who
of Arabic background for a long long
time. And every time it comes out, and
it's funny because I look at comments
and a lot of people are like, "I can't
find this. I can't find this." Well,
yeah. That's what I've seen over and
over. You think you're going to find it?
Of course you're not going to find it
because it keeps getting, you know,
suppressed and deleted. I know it's
still out there and you can find it if
you look in the right places, but this
isn't something that they're trying to
advertise or talk about. So, it is hard
to find online, but I did see it with my
own eyes in books and I know it's out
there and and you can find it in in
correct um Ahmed bin Hul's uh you know
there's PDFs in English and Arabic which
I've accessed and I I know you have too.
Um so it's a real thing. It's there. And
it's interesting just to look at all the
different sort of, you know,
apolog, you know, sideline the issue.
And what's interesting is how they
contradict each other because I've
watched a lot of different Muslims um,
you know, attack this particular hadith,
try to give you try to correct the
meaning, you know, tell you what we
think it means and they contradict each
other. And so, okay, I'll give you some
examples of what's being said. All
right. So first of all it's mainstream
amongst Muslims that what's being
described here are jin okay these are
jin these are not humans even though uh
in the hadith it says in the Arabic it
says and that's how I translated
it al in other words people who appeared
to be alot doesn't say they were alot
but they kind of it seems like they're
the alz now who are alot and when you
look into the ethnographic and literary
evidence from that time the zut and
apparently you can even trace
etmologically the name goes back to
peoples in in India or in modern day
Pakistan who are I think today they're
called the jat z I've gotten tons of
tons of those comments from people
saying hey these are the jot or some
people are saying yeah yep these are the
jot and yet that's uh and then other
people saying hey that's that's my group
yes we are like that yeah I know they're
very proud of it okay they're proud of
that yeah they're very proud of it but
what's What what really got me is uh you
know this whole chat GBT thing. I've
been having you know I've been
entertaining myself with it. I don't
take it too seriously but I like to play
games with it and I'm kind of I it's
amusing. So I actually play head games
with it by which I mean um you know if I
asked it and I did so I use different um
IPs different browsers etc. And I asked
two sets of questions and the first was
there's some there's a hadith about
these people who are called zuts and
apparently they ride the prophet are
they jin or humans and immediately told
me no these are jin this has nothing to
do with humans and and it also tried to
correct me no it's not riding etc etc
and then on another day you know like I
said through a whole different IP and
everything I just randomly asked him and
I said are I didn't mention the hadith I
just said are the zut jin or humans. And
it immediately it said and I can send
you I actually took screenshots. I can
send them to you. But it immediately
said um no no the zuts are humans uh and
and basically from Pakistan or whatever.
And then I also um you know I quoted
various uh Islamic texts that I had read
and I wanted to see if chat GBT knows
about that where they talk about their
large and prominent genitalia. So in the
Arabic sources, the Arabic literary
sources when you read about
al they are akin to alzenj and alzen are
the black people of Africa but alot
apparently are Asiatic uh you know
Hindus they're darkkinned but they're
not Africans okay but they get grouped
together in the ethnographies of the
Arab peoples and their prominent
characteristics is they're sort of
strong athletic tall lean and they all
dwell on their large genitalia and that
they're used also for sort of, you know,
viral purposes and they're very I mean
you get this if you've read the Arabian
Knights or the 101 Arabian Knights, this
is how dark-kinned peoples are always
portrayed. So whether it's a trope or
reality, whatever, that's how it's
understood. Okay. Um, and when I asked
GP uh chat GBT and I didn't mention the
hadith, it said yes, they're humans. And
then I asked that, can you describe them
to me? And that's exactly what it said
as you saw in the video. That that is
verbatim. Okay. Um, so the first thing
to to note is this whole business about
jin. So why do they say it's jin? They
say it's jin because in the Quran
there's two references to the jin and
Muhammad re, you know, yak reading the
Quran to them. He's trying to convert
them. And of course in the Quran it's
very short stories as usual in the
Quran. You can't get any details. We
don't know where it is, when it is, how
many times was this once, several times.
But apparently he read the Quran or
recited the Quran to the Jin and they
were all amazed by it. And in the Quran
it says they finally learned that God
does not begget or or have a wife which
of course is a swipe at Christianity. Um
and then they run to their fellow gin
folk and explain to them that you know
Muhammad's a true prophet and they all
come and listen to him. All right. Then
there's a hadith portion. All right. And
there are hadith where they talk about
jin meeting with Muhammad and a lot of
people will so they'll tell you this is
these two correlate right the Quran
correlates with the hadith about the jin
meeting with Muhammad but now the
question remains what we're talking
about this particular hadith are those
jin or are they not okay we've already
seen that um according to the historical
sources these are humans according to
common sense if you want to take a sort
of secular worldview they're humans
they're not jin And I should before I
forget, I should add that, you know,
when they say that it's the jin and you
know, let's say they're trying to get
away from the whole sexual aspect, you
can't because the jin according to the
Quran have sex. They have genitalia.
They copulate. So telling us that the
zoots were jin and they were writing
Muhammad doesn't help. All right. And
they're also made of fire, which implies
that their members are made of fires.
All right. So, you know, it actually
gets more graphic. That would account
for the that would account for the pain.
Yeah, exactly. All right. It would
account for the pain. And um you know, I
told you there's a sort of double
meaning here. The word which we can talk
about a little bit. Yabun, which is in
Arabic. When people tell you that
doesn't mean ride, no. Yabun, anyone who
tells you that, who tells you doesn't
mean ride is a liar. It means I have the
dictionary right here. I can pull it up
in front of you. I have two dictionaries
and it's a whole page. You know how
dictionaries give you the the main
meaning. Then they go into subtle
meanings. about half a page it's all
ride mount hop on okay that's what y
kaboon means um but now the the new
apologetic is no no it doesn't mean that
it meant they were crowding around him
because they were so eager to hear the
recitation of the Quran all right um but
no but the other meaning that I didn't
mention in the video of
yakabun Arabic it means to possess okay
so if these were jin or supernatural be
beings till this very day if I'm
speaking Arabic and I want to tell you
that a spirit or a demon origin
possessed so- and so I say reabu same
verb like to ride him to get on top of
him to dominate him all right um so you
know they can't get away from that
problem but they're trying so now they
bring the all right so now let's go to
this particular hadith I've already told
you the Quran says there's jin and then
there are hadith which try to associate
it with that particular Quranic
rendition and no one really even knows
if they're talking about the thing
because like I said, the Quran's very
amorphous. But this particular thing,
what they're trying to do is tell you,
okay, even so, even though it says alot,
it doesn't really mean the people. It's
saying they kind of looked like them. So
these were dark-kinned genies, right?
Okay. Apparently, um, and then they try
to tell you, no, no, because they were
so eager to hear, like I said, Muhammad,
they were so crowding him. But there is
nowhere I I just looked through two
pages of the translation of the word
yakab and nowhere does it appear as
crowding or being around someone. It
literally means to mount to ride. The
first few sentences of the word yabun it
says to ride a horse to ride an animal.
Okay, to ride and then later on there's
the sexual connotation as I mentioned.
All right, so the first thing that
Muslims have to have to explain is what
is this talking about? Okay. Ride ride
ride kaboon does not necessarily have to
be sex. I agree. It means like riding a
horse. So what these guys came and all
night rode Muhammad like a horse. They
were playing around all night. And is
that what hurt him? Because as you know
the hadith ends up with him limping and
being in extreme pain. And the Arabic
you know the the English translations
don't do it justice but the Arabic says
that he was in pain
from which doesn't mean from from riding
him. It means from that which they did
rioting him. All right. So it's even
more explicit. Um so these are the
issues that Muslims have to deal with
and like I said they've kind of wavered
one by insisting no you're you're you're
getting it wrong. These are jin and
they're not writing him. They're just
listening to him. And then there's
another kind of apology which basically
says all right there is the night of the
jin and we know that Abdullahbin Mass
the narrator of the hadith in question
was not present at the night of the jin.
So therefore it's a weak and completely
uh worthless hadith. All right so even
in their own in their own arguments are
contradicting one each other one one
another. Um but but Abdullahb Masoud is
actually a chief transmitter of hadith.
He's very well known, very well
respected. If he and if you look at
Ahmed bin Hamb's musid where this hadith
first occurs, it's considered
sahir who you mentioned earlier when he
talks about this hadith he literally
says this hadith is very strange but he
does not say it's weak or it's fake. All
right? Because it he doesn't know what
to make of it. So you know we can use
our common sense and try to you know
deduce what we're talking about here. uh
you can say and obviously again I like
to tell you what people are saying
because I don't want to take
responsibility for this. Um a because I
didn't come up with this. I've watched
people talk about it. So it's it's not
of my own you know this isn't my own
deduction and uh you know b just to let
you know what's really being said in the
Muslim Arab-speaking world and it is
what I summarized which is basically
Muhammad had a rendevu pre-planned with
these well-known you know large black
athletic looking men from India
dark-kinned not not black African um who
are known for prominent genitalia and he
told his friend for whatever reason hey
you stay here and then he went off and
they rode him literally all night
because uh Abdullah Mas people ask me
where does it say all night? Well, he
says we went out into the desert night
came and then this goes on till daybreak
until the dawn of the sun. All right.
So, and then that's when Muhammad comes
back. Or if you want to go with this jin
uh theory, it really doesn't make it
much better because the jin are actually
car they can have sex including with
humans. All right? And they can the word
which means right also means to possess.
So this doesn't really help matters if
you say it is the jin which is what they
try to say. And this is why I think in
the end a lot of them are just trying to
say no no it is a jin and abdah was not
at the present at the night of the jin
because in the hadith Abdullah says I
wish I was there. All right. And so
therefore, it's a completely fabricated
hadith. Whereas a lot of other Muslims
say, "No, no, it is real." And we try to
keep it with the jin thing. But like I
said, there's no reason to doubt
Abdullah because we if it's not the
night of the jin, then yeah, he was
there. Why wouldn't he be there if he
said he was? And so as far as the uh
meaning of rode him, as far as the
meaning of rode him, so the main the
main definition would be like riding an
animal. Uh but then there's a sexual
meaning similar to
she was writing him like in English and
so on. Um and then uh then there's the
spiritual meaning of possessed. So as
far as whether this was
men whether this was men or they were
jin as far as translating the the
translation that would make least sense
is writing him like an animal. Like if
that that would that translation would
make the least sense. If it's a sexual
connotation, that would seem to make the
most sense. Uh, if it's talking about
and keep in mind and keep in mind that
he's in pain, if they're writing him
like they're play horse acting, you
know, all right, but uh that he's in
pain implies the the latter suggestion,
you know, the sexual and and so if it's
human beings, the most obvious meaning
of them writing him would be the sexual
meaning. If it's referring to jin,
then two meanings would you're pointing
out. The two meanings would would make
both would make sense. Either Yeah.
Equal e either sexual either sexual
meaning or they actually possessed him
for the night and or both at the same
time. Maybe that's how they possess or
both. They're banging a man possessing
him. Mhm. That's true. And as you and as
you of all people know that um you know
there's a lot of accusations against
Muhammad of being you know in league
with demon forces um and and you know
there's the idea that demons uh whether
it's a succubus or incubus and they you
know copulate with humans. I mean I you
know let your mind go wild with what it
could be. And the point is it's a very
problematic hadith as you can see. And
uh I mean as far as Muhammad's first
impression uh of his revelations in the
cave according to Iban Assak, he thought
he was possessed by something. Yeah. And
it's actually his his wife and her
cousin who convinced him, "No, you're a
prophet." Well, he was convinced what
whatever was pressing on him. might be
interested in some possible
interpretations of what that could mean
in light of really really in light of
what we just came across. What what was
pressing me? Yeah. Yeah. All right. So,
I'd like to get giant doc's thoughts on
this. We'll just take these couple super
chats here because a couple of these are
for you Raymond. Uh but we in the biz
call this topic the goats revenge. Very
rude that is from the channel Goat Hub.
Um although it is a favorite channel of
uh lots of Pakistani uh guys. Uh, Cinco
de Mayo was originally a pagan holiday
until Constantine Christianized at the
Council of Nika. Yeah, that's a this is
an ongoing joke that uh Well, yeah. Uh,
AP looks more muscular today. Yeah. Some
people call you buff AP because I'm
normally live with AP. I I I finally get
the reference now. Yeah. So, he says,
"AP looks more muscular today. Love your
work, Raymond, and your alzid. You
didn't shy away from being blunt and
well ballsy. Christ is risen." Oh, hi,
David. Thanks. And Sarah here says they
rode him all night long. That's what
they do. Yeah, that is what they uh
Oh, yeah. There's a bunch of songs. I I
thought about putting that into my
video. You got to play that song. Yeah,
you got to you got to like I was I was
concerned about the copyright thing
because sometimes they'll let you slide
if it's a short clip and other time
they'll just flag you if they'll flag
you instantly, especially if it's a
chorus of a song. But yeah, all night
long. I could have just sang it. That
would have been that would have been do
it in or do it in Arabic, you know. Get
the Arabic version.
Yeah. Ah boy. All right. So Jai doc
yo. Uh so we'll uh share our screen
here. We have we do have some slides on
this. So um we found uh a very rare uh
Muslim
site where it's called
sunnat.com. Sunn22 as in the
digit2.com/262. It's in the Arabic and
the English and it's correct.
Um, and the part here that you want,
they actually put the put their kabun um
in the red, brother Amond, in the red.
Yep. There it is. Yeah, there it is.
There it is. There it is. And um they
put it in the English as well. Your
kabun
did they put ride in English? They did.
And they came and started to Okay. Oh,
nice. Ride. Yeah. Okay. That's proper
that's proper Arabic. Good. Yeah. So,
here we have a Muslim translation. And
you can see cuz they put like saw and
all these other things Muslim right well
Muslim translation and they're look
they're actually agreeing. So, and look
what he said here. Sound chain of
narration.
At the
end, it's Yeah. Yeah. So, um, we
actually went Why don't you read
actually what you can read those
underlined parts, you know, to see how
well they accord with my because I just
kind of paraphrase it. But yeah. Okay.
Shall we shall we do it? So, yeah. Um,
yeah. Uh, so yeah. Um we'll go through
the underlined parts here. Uh then he
the narrator mentioned a group of male
members hanin.
Yeah. Yeah. That's the word that's the
word they use. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Who
looked like zut
people said Allah willing with no
clothes on but I did not see their
genitals tall and
scrawny. And they came and started to
ride. And then he put in between the
word the Arabic word
messenger. Yeah. The messenger of Allah.
And the prophet began to recite to them
and they started to move closer and lean
around me and get in my way. Meaning um
is talking and I became intensely
terrified of them. So I sat down and
when the morning broke, morning light
broke like what you said brother, they
began to go away. Then the messenger of
Allah came back exhausted and in pain or
practically in pain from how much from
how they had ridden him. See how how
they had ridden him. Not just not just
that they wrote him how they rode him.
Yeah. That's a very accurate
translation. Good for them. Yeah. here
in the Arabic.
Yeah.
Yeah. Uh he said indeed I am exhausted.
I feel so weak
for some reason.
Then the messenger of Allah put his head
in my lap. Yes. Very similar to the uh
Yeah. Kalby story. Yeah. The Kalby
story. Matter of fact, I'll I'll pull
those I'll pull those up here in a few
minutes and we'll take a look at the uh
eerie similarities. You see a lot of
parallels there. Yeah. Mhm. And the
scrawny ones came with tall white
garments on. But the messenger of Allah
had fallen asleep and I became more
intensely terrified than I was the first
time. Yep. And sound chain Muslim Ahmed.
And we thought, you know, because
Muslims as as uh the brother said,
Raymond said that they they put a big
deal on what does this word mean in the
Arabic. So what we thought was hey why
don't we go to some verses in the Quran
where you have it used in different
forms like different verbal forms and
what do we see so you can surah 16:8 you
can appreciate it looks the same similar
sorry here it says and he created horses
mules and donkeys for you to ride to
ride so the ride is so what what what
they're showing you here is look in the
Arabic on top the red that's the exact
same word used about what the zoot did
now look Look at the translation down
there. Ride. You see? That is that's the
only meaning for it. But now they try to
twist it around and tell you no, no,
there's other meanings for it. The only
thing you can or ride is like an animal.
Either that or like I said, there's a
sexual connotation.
Exactly. Yeah. And it's not the only
one. We've got another one. Surah
4079. It's Allah who made for you the
grazing animals upon which you ride.
Good job.
Thank you. See
here similar and the smoking gun 43
verse2 you see see how similar these are
now look now it's mounts you see same
thing ride or mount he created for you
all species all of them has made for you
ships and animals those wish you mounts
so ships as in you know like boats
hey we don't have uh uh for for everyone
for everyone who's watching uh we're
talking about Ibn Massud here. So, Ibn
Mass Masud, leave that up. Leave that up
for a second. But uh Ibn Mass Masud was
um is the guy in this story who's
watching from behind the diddy line. And
uh for all you who who don't know, Ibn
Massud comes up a lot when we're talking
about the preservation of the Quran
because uh he objected to the current
Quran when it was put out and and to uh
uh um man burning all the Qurans. He
even told he even told his followers,
"Hide your Qurans. do not hand them over
to the do not hand them over to these
guys to to burn them. Um, but anyway,
he's one of four people that Muhammad
said, if you want to learn the Quran,
learn it from anybody. And he listed
Iban Masoud as his top Quran reciter.
But we don't actually have Ib Massud's
Quran anymore. Wouldn't it be
interesting if we found Iben Masoud's
Quran? And this verse actually said,
"And who created the species, all of
them, and has made for you of ships and
animals, those which you mount, like the
men of Alz mounted Muhammad as I stood
behind the diddy line, watching in
terror, sitting on my rear end, lest
they do unto me what they were doing to
my beloved prophet." That would be
funny. No wonder they covered up his
Quran and and and demanded that it be
burned.
Yeah. Uh I'm glad you guys brought this
up. Uh, I'm glad you guys brought this
up because, you know, I really
summarized it in English in that little
video, but as you can see, this is kind
of verbatim exactly what it's almost
worse than the way I presented it. Yeah.
And uh, so at the at the very end uh,
they give like a summary of all the
different scholarly views. And so what
Muslims will do was Muslims will
highlight, oh, this scholar said it was
weak or that scholar said it was weak.
So what we did, we did the opposite. We
showed which ones say that it's actually
good. It's actually authentic. So Bkari
reported it. Yes. We know Bkari was a
report is the top one. Yeah. Uh we
seemed as well. He said it's which we
have. This is a very strange uh wording
unless you go to the Muslim. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. What does it mean? Well, we go to
the to the Islam web and they define it
for us. So it says the the the hadith
which says is stronger than the which he
says only. So like it means strange but
when you put it in this context when he
says it it actually is it means it's
stronger. It's more authentic.
Yeah. And uh and then the the editors of
this uh volume here they say we say that
the men
of their trustworthy.
It's men of Yep. So they're authentic,
you know,
narrators as well. This is another
famous name. Uh, you know, and so we
have like the various uh things here. So
if everyone wants to screenshot it or
whatever, you guys want to share this.
This is a like I said, you'll find other
ones that say that it's weak and things,
but we'll let the Muslims highlight that
stuff because that's what they've been
doing, but they're not highlighting the
ones that say it's it's authentic. Yeah,
we do have like you said brother saying
is very strange but he didn't say it was
weak. Correct. But we we we just got the
um the summary of of you know he just
said they're they're all men of
authentic authentic hotness. Yes. Very
good. So yes that's a that's what we
have. It's very helpful. Yeah.
Interesting interesting stuff. Um, so,
um, that's Can I give you a quick
summary because I'm I've grown scenile
in my elder age and I just want to give
you a one minute like the point of all
this, right? Absolutely. And the point
of all this Thanks. The point of all
this is all right. You either can say
it's fake and as we saw a lot of people
say it's not, and there's good reason
not to say it's fake. And if you don't
say it's fake, I don't care if you say
it's humans or if you say it's jin, it's
a problem because you got either humans
or you got jin who we know populate with
humans and possess them. And both of
them, both groups are riding and
mounting the prophet all night long to
the point that he's in a lot of pain and
he comes and faints exhausted in the lap
of his friend. Okay, so that's I think
what Muslims have to deal with. It's
there. And you know, just calling it Jin
is not gonna get you out of the out of
the hole. That's the problem. It makes
it even worse. So, definitely makes it
worse and doesn't get you out of the
hole.
No pun.
Come on. Uh, keep it clean.
So, uh, yeah, very weird. Very, very
weird stuff. So, yeah, guys. So, they're
basically they're basically two main
issues here. So one is did this happen
and there there would be kind of a range
of perspectives on this issue like one
it happened exactly like it's recorded
in the various hadith and so on or two
it didn't happen at all it's just
completely fabricated or something
something in there in between like uh
there's something that happened
something really weird that happened and
then you know Muslims try to uh try to
uh doctor it in various doctor the story
in various ious ways um by uh changing
details or adding or modifying the story
as time goes on. So that's one issue. Uh
what here is actually authentic and
that's one of the ways the story is
challenged by saying it's a uh it's a
weak hadith or something like that and
giant doc pointed out nope there are
plenty of there are plenty of Muslims
who uh great who grade this uh this
story as uh as reliable. But I I have to
point out because all you non-Muslims
who are watching um don't make the
mistake of falling into the idea that
that we always have to agree with their
methodology and so on. I think their
methodology is massively screwed up uh
as far as how they weed out information.
You have you have they'll basically
here's the issue, ladies and gentlemen.
The
methodology is developed over time. the
methodology has developed over time as
far as that's why you'll find these
sources included um in these collections
and it's later Muslims who are saying no
that's unreliable or that's that's
reliable and so on because they're
coming up with a methodology and so on
and actually if you if you look at
um if you look at what
non-Muslim hadith scholars there aren't
a lot of them there are a few non-Muslim
hadith scholars they actually look at
these gradings completely differently
and it's almost the opposite. When they
see a perfect chain of perfectly
reliable transmitters, it's almost along
the lines of the principle of
embarrassment. They look at that and say
that is that looks like something that
was fabricated. Why? Because they didn't
have this methodology didn't exist at
the beginning. You had people just
sharing stories and stuff like this. But
as far as here are the requirements for
a sahi hadith that comes later and
that's developed over time. And so when
they see a perfect chain, they look at
that as that looks like a chain that
someone would have invented if they were
making up a story. When they see a
broken chain or a chain that includes uh
unreliable narrators, they think, "Oh,
that shows that that hadith is actually
earlier." Because if you were
fabricating, if you were fabricating a
hadith later on after the methodology
had been invented, you would have given
it you would have given it a perfect
list of transmitters. If you were just
making it up, keep in mind if you want
to make up a story, you can make up a a
list of transmitters and so on. And so
if this story was from later after the
methodology had been developed and
you're inventing a hadith, you would
obviously invent a chain of perfectly
reliable transmitters. And so if you see
a a weak hadith, it's very interesting
situation when Muslim when your average
Muslim sees weak hadith, he goes, "Oh,
can't believe that." When you're talking
about the non-Muslim hadith scholars,
they go, "Oh, weak chain, weak chain.
That's that's means it's probably better
than the perfect chain because the
perfect chain is more likely to be
invented and the weak chain is less
likely to be invented and so they
actually take that more seriously as
something that comes from earlier. Uh
the point is guys um when they say when
Muslims say oh it's a weak hadith you
can't use it or you can't quote it or
something like that do do not do not do
not fall for that. It's like when they
come to our sources do we say here's our
methodology and you have to use our
methodology. Are they going to take that
seriously? Here's the Bible. It's the
it's the uh it's the infallible word of
God and you have to treat it as such for
throughout the duration of this uh
discussion. Are they going to accept
that? No. They don't even accept it when
we show that their book affirms our
book. They don't even they won't even go
with what Allah says about our book when
he tells us to go by our book and to
judge by our book and so on. So, they
won't even go with Allah's methodology
about our book, let alone ours. So, the
point is um Muslims can say, "Hey, from
our perspective, we would not we're not
going to use this uh hadith. We think
it's weak. We're free to say we don't
have a lot of confidence in your
methodology and therefore we're going to
use this we're going to use this source
anyway even if it was just a weak
hadith. My point is if even if you have
a hadith or something like that that
they would regard as completely weak we
can use that and apply actual historical
principles. We can treat it just like a
historical source and say is this does
this look like something that's
authentic? Does this look like something
that's going to be fabricated? We can
use actual principles of historians to
uh to examine these sources and not
their methodology which historians
actually think is
pretty they don't think it's the only
way to do history like Muslims do. Um
with that
said, you've got with with that said,
you have plenty of Muslim scholars who
do not grade this as a weak hadith and
therefore Muslims have a problem. So
that's one issue is did this actually
happen? Is this a reliable source? Is
this something that's based on something
that actually happened? And then the
other issue is what in the name of
common sense does this mean? What is
this about? What is all of this about?
Is this about jin uh writing Muhammad or
possessing Muhammad? Is this about men
of Alz
um doing something to Muhammad? Uh is it
sexual? Is it something else? Uh, I have
to say I have to say um I've been saying
this for a
while, but when you've got all these
Muslim when you've got all these Muslim
da guys and they'll just flat out lie
and they'll say Rebecca in the Bible's
three. And they'll say that in response
to saying that uh Aisha was nine, we'll
say, "Hey, why is why did Muhammad have
sex with a nine-year-old girl?" And
they'll say, "Oh, but Rebecca in the
Bible was three." And we'll say,
"Chapter and verse, show us that." It's
just a lie. It's just a lie. Um they'll
lie. They'll say uh they'll say, "But
the Catholic Encyclopedia says Mary was
12 when she got pregnant." It does not.
It says the opposite. It says, "We have
no idea." And so when all your da guys
are spreading lies, guess what? I'm not
going to tell Christians to lie in
response. There's no there's no scenario
I'm going to say lie. You you could you
could say if you're joking or something,
that's one thing. But I'm not going to
tell Christians to lie in response to
lies. I will say don't give the benefit
of the doubt uh in response. If you're
dealing with a bunch of guys who are
lying and they think it's fine to lie
about people in the Bible, Mary, Jesus,
uh Abraham, Isaac, and so on. They just
think it's free to lie. Okay, don't tell
me to give you the benefit of the doubt
of something in your sources sounds
really, really messed up. I'll go
exactly what I'll go with exactly what
it sounds like. And so on this story
just sounds like something pretty creepy
and you guys oh go with the go with our
scholars who said it's weak and don't
believe that it happened. No. Why would
I do that? It looks like something real.
It doesn't look like something that
someone would make up. Uh and then what
does it sound
like? It sounds like either this was
some dudes that met with Muhammad out in
the desert for a late night uh orgy.
That's what it sounds like. uh and that
and that Ibn Massud maybe Muhammad just
liked people watching and so I want
someone watching and then it looks like
a story where Iben Massud starts passing
this story around. Man, you guys aren't
going to believe what I saw in the
desert the other night with Muhammad and
and then over time Muslims start, oh
maybe it was just jin, maybe it was just
jin not realizing this doesn't help
because now you got jin who are banging
their prophet and so on or possessing
him or both. So yeah, I'm not inclined
to just give you the benefit of the
doubt on anything uh anymore. Just got
to go with what this stuff just got to
go with what this stuff looks
like. Um let me uh let me throw out a
little
apmic for Muslims that I've been
watching. So when this comes up and they
try to show Christians, oh you shouldn't
interpret it the way as you just
delineated it, which I agree with uh you
David. Um, and they're like, "Why would
you delineate it that way?" And and and
then they say, "Well, what if we took
the gospel where," and I'm pretty sure
it's the gospel of John where, you know,
the the the beloved the beloved disciple
or apostle John lays his head on the lap
or on the bosom of Jesus and they say,
"Oh, well, look, we can twist this
around. We can turn it into a homosexual
affair. We can do this and that." And my
point, and it's kind of like, no, that's
pretty weak. It's one thing to put your
head on the bosom of someone who you
love. I mean, children do to their moms
and their dads. Okay, it's another thing
to go and ride someone all night long.
Um, and that's really the difficulty
that they got to deal with. And that's
why they play all these semantic games
and try to twist the word, the Arabic
word yer kabun to try to tell you
doesn't mean what it means, but it means
exactly what it means. Um, the only time
you use that word is to write an animal.
Okay? And then the other thing is, okay,
so let's say it's not sex. All right?
Okay. So they wrote him like what? He
Muhammad got on all fours and they were
playing around. I'm a donkey and he sat
on top of him. Yeah. And and you know
and then again would that really hurt
him to the point that he can't walk and
he's limping from how they rode him the
way the the way it was translated. So
it's really it's very you know like you
like like the cafir thing. It's just
this it's a weird oddity. We don't know
how to make sense of it. And so the
easiest way of course for most Muslims
to tell you, oh yeah, it's a it's a DI
or a weak hadith and but you know you
see that all the time with Muslims where
something's not it's you know the chain
of transmission whether it's good or bad
or whatever but it's it's in it's in the
hadith and it gets in other words
amongst Muslims nowadays what's weak
something that's embarrassing and what's
strong is something that's not
embarrassing and decent or neutral. All
right. But the fact is this particular
hadith and Muslim bin Hul and there's
other books. I put a few of them.
There's even more. I didn't put them in
my um in the detail box and they're all
being taught in Alazar. And see this is
the issue. It's Allahar of course would
be the most prestigious Islamic
university. Whatever it teaches is
considered mainstream Sunni Islam. And
uh it's kind of like well if this is
something embarrassing or you don't want
or why don't you get rid of it? You see
what I mean? you can't you can't keep it
and you can't keep it in your texts and
you can't teach it and then when we
bring it up you tell us oh yeah it's not
real we don't really accept it and that
seems to be the case with so many
problematic hadiths they keep them they
use them and then when they get exposed
they tell you no no it's weak you don't
have to don't worry about it or they or
they change the trans or they change the
translation u but yeah you're right this
is this is an issue that keeps keeps
coming up over and over again it's like
if you go back 15 years. That's why I
brought up the the claim that Aisha was
actually way older. She was 18 to 20 and
so on. That's from like 15 years ago
when the Muslim argument, one of the
most common Muslim arguments was
Muhammad's character was so perfect, he
had to actually be from God. There's no
way a guy could have a character this
perfect uh unless God is actually um
with him. And so, so we started pointing
out things like Muhammad and Aisha.
What' they say back then? You're a liar.
You're a liar. That's no that's a that's
a fabrication. That's a that's a weak
hadith. and so on. That's what they said
back then. Now, now pretty much all the
Dawa guys acknowledge this. Why? Because
we kept we kept pushing. And uh then you
have the translation issue that comes up
over and over again. Like there are
there are hadith there's the hadith that
where Aisha says Muhammad struck me in
my chest which caused me pain. And so as
soon as we would point that out, hey, it
says I it says Muhammad hit her in her
chest. Then all of a sudden after we use
that for a while, then they'll change
the translation. It'll say he gave me a
he gave me a shove. Um, and so they'll
actually modify their translations when
they start realizing that we're using
something against uh against Islam. You
have the tongue sucking hadith where
Muhammad's sucking on the tongue of his
uh grandsons and so on. And then that
they'll change that those translations
now and so on. So yeah, every time we
use something for a while, they'll start
arguing for different translations and
basically all their responses even going
with, "Oh, that's just weak hadith,
that's just this, that's just that." Or,
"Ha, you don't know the Arabic for this
or that." It's like they're taking
advantage of people's ignorance because,
you know, a regular person who finds out
about this and brings this to his Muslim
friends and says, "Hey, what's going on
with this? It's a it's a Muhammad out in
the desert and uh they're doing
something." No, no, it doesn't mean what
you think. It means something different.
Oh, it's a weak hadith. All scholars
grant that this is weak. You know, they
could just make things up because your
average person, even someone who hears
this story, isn't going to know how to
respond to these things. And then
they'll say, "Oh, it doesn't mean right.
It means, you know, they're crowding
around him or something like that." But
that but that's why I'm telling you, you
know, to Arab speakers and Arab
listeners, this does not work at all. We
all know what that word means 110%. All
right? So they they can they can pull
that off. You're right amongst, you
know, ignorant non-Arab speaking people,
but to Arab speakers, and I'm sure like
Jai doc, they'll agree. When you hear
that word, okay, I know exactly what
that means. It either means you're
riding an animal or you're mounting or
you're doing something sexual. It
doesn't mean anything else than that.
Everyone knows that. Um, but you're
right. They of course play around and
they twist it around. And if you don't
know any better, well, you're gonna
you're gonna defer to the Arab speaker
who's telling you you're wrong. Okay?
But I'm one of them. I'm telling you,
you're not. That's what it means. And
so, for everyone who's watching, I'm
pointing this out because uh again, this
happens over and over again. We bring
something we bring something to the
light to popularize it. And then as you
go out and try to and share this
information with other people, you'll
get, "Haha, you're ignorant. You don't
know what you're you're talking about.
it's weak, it's this, it's that, you
can't trust this, you don't know what
the Arabic means, and so on. Just know,
keep pushing. Eventually, the truth
works its way. And, you know, all the
responses we're giving, eventually, they
will be corrected on all this stuff. And
if you fast forward 5 years from now,
this will just be taken taken for
granted as something weird and creepy.
Weird and creepy about Muhammad. So,
yeah, that's a among the many other
things. Yeah, among the many, many,
many, many, many other things. In fact,
I'll share one here in a second. I'll I
I did want to point out an eerie
parallel with uh with the story of Dia
Albby. Oh, by the way, Giant Doc, I
understand it's late over there. I
wanted you guys to share that because
you actually had uh uh you had uh you
had the s some of the uh stuff you
wanted to put on the screen as far as um
the source and then with the Quran and
so on, but I understand it's late over
there. So, if you guys need to cut out,
just you can you can cut. Yeah, we'll
just uh Yeah, we'll just say one one
last thing. Uh we agree with uh you guys
100% on that. And what we tell Muslims
all the time is hey if you guys can show
us in the dictionary then prove us
wrong. Show me rabba in the dictionary
means to crowd. Yeah. Go ahead. That's
it. Because you're not going to win
otherwise to say ride is the crowd. It
sounds exactly the same as in English if
I tell you ride is to crowd. Like it
sounds just as it sounds weird to your
ears. Just as ridiculous. But let me
show you right here. I don't know if you
can see it. Okay. Here's here's the most
respected Arab Muslim uh uh Arabic to
English dictionary, the Hans Ver
dictionary. And I'm trying to show you
the the oraba. And you see I don't see
how if you can see how long it is. None
of that says crowd. It's all variations.
It's all variations of ride, mount, get
on top of, and have sex with. So yeah,
exactly. That's the thing. See, like if
you were to ask Shad GBT and say, "Hey,
I have a hadith." And and and and it
sees that it's people riding Muhammad,
it's going to tell you, "No, no, it
means this means that." But if you just
ask it the word, the Arabic word, it's
going to go, "Yeah, of course it means
ride." Uh so that's these are the kind
of games we're constantly confronting.
And it's it's an issue with uh chat GPT
and Grock and all these. Um, you
basically have to, as you're pointing
out, you kind of have to trick it into
giving accurate information. Because
here's the thing, everyone, because they
do this with me, I'll make a claim and
then even non-Muslims will go, "No, I
checked with Chat GPT and it said this
is false and you're making this up." And
it's like, they don't realize when you
ask ChatGpt or Grock something, they're
searching for on online content about
this, guess what? They're getting the
responses of the DA guys. They're
getting the responses of Muslims in
there and they're taking it and saying,
"Oh, no." Cuz the word doesn't mean that
cuz they they're including in their
analysis all these Muslim responses and
they don't do a good job distinguishing
between someone who's lying and someone
who's telling the truth. A computer
doesn't I mean a a software or program
or a bot doesn't understand, oh, this
guy is just trying to defend his profit
and is making things up. They don't know
that kind they don't know that kind of
stuff. And so, uh, yeah. No, no, but I
if I if I can interject while I agree
with you, it no this this thing is
sinister enough because I was play I
decided, you know, I was having an adult
beverage one night and I was deciding to
play games with chat GBT and I started
off asking it, you know, what seemingly
innocent questions and I kept building
up to it and I finally basically I was
it was about Islam and I was asking it
things and it gave me the politically
correct answers like you're saying and
then finally I was like I I asked it was
something like this hadith and I was
like is hear a story about Muhammad
being uh mounted or written by men or
genies? It was like no there's no such
thing. And then I wrote, well, what
about the hadith in Ahmed bin Hul where
it says, and I said, oh, well, yeah. Oh,
that one. That one, but I thought you
wanted, you know, like it it
understands. It's actually I mean when
they call
not just um an automatic thing which I
would think it is like you but I it has
a it it actually you know there's some
kind of synaptic nerves going on and it
kind of understand and it's it's and
it's it's a dangerous apologist
basically.
Uh a couple questions here. Dr. Ibrahim,
would you consider the Crusades as
successes or failures? Why in your
opinion why did Christian Europe fail to
retake Jerusalem? He's asking some uh
well yeah I mean ultimately obviously
there were failures there's no way
around that because the goal was
Jerusalem and they lost it for
Christendom. Um and in your opinion why
did cure Oh well and the reason is
because Europe lost its Christianity. So
it's uh the crusaders if you really look
at it and that's what my most recent
book is about. We'll talk about it at
some point when it comes when it gets
closer. But uh it just shows you how
over the centuries after the first
crusade, you know, the core of the
people who believed in crusader ideals
kept shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking until they were nobody but the
military orders, you know, the knights
of the temple and the hospital and the
Tutonic Knights and so forth. Um and uh
you know, these guys were still like the
first crusaders and if you had a lot of
them like you did in the first crusade,
yeah, you could have actually the
crusaders would have been a success. But
really the sort of secularization of the
west and Europe um that's been going on
for centuries and you can really watch
it's pretty interesting to see how it
happened. Um and and I would say that is
really the real reason that the crusades
ultimately failed because you went from
having let's say 90% of European
Christians maintaining those ideals to
in 15600 having maybe 20%. Um, and then
in in 2025, well, you know, nothing
because men are men think they're women.
So, anyway, there there's a yeah, there
was a study uh UK study um of how many
people would be willing to fight for
their nation if they had to. And among
the young generation, so like the 18 to
34 or whatever it is, it was like 11% of
people if if it was a matter of saving
their country, would they fight for it
was like 11%. And so pretty darn bad.
Um, yep. I did want to share the sort of
eerie parallel here. Let me bring this
up. So look at this.
This Sunni source narrated Abu Uman. I
got the news that Jabriel came to the
prophet while um Salom was present.
Jabriel started talking to the prophet
and then left. The prophet said to um
Salom, do you know who it was? Or a
similar question. She said, "It was the
a handsome person amongst the companions
of the prophet." Later on, um Salma
said, "By Allah, I thought he was none
but Deha till I heard the prophet
talking about Gabriel and his religious
talk." So, uh, guys, you understand
what's going on here? Oo, Salma sees
Muhammad with a guy and she assumes it's
Da Al Kali, who is known for being a
handsomest young man in Arabia. So,
she's uh that's what she thinks. And
then later, Muhammad makes it clear that
when you see him in his house with Dea
Alcali, it's actually the angel Gabriel
that he's with. And it's funny because
we have this in both Sunni and Shia
sources.
Yeah, this is a Shia. This is a Shia
source. So this is
Alcafi. And so once Abu Dar came to the
messenger of Allah while Gabriel was in
the form of Dea Al- Kalbi, one of the
companions of the holy prophet in a
private meeting with the messenger of
Allah. So there would be these private
meetings and they all think it's Dea
Alcali, but it's actually the angel
Gabriel. And you go down in the next
paragraph. When Jabriel Gabriel left,
Abu Dar came to the holy prophet and the
messenger of Allah said to him, "Oh Abu
Dar, what stopped you from offering us
the greeting of peace when you passed
by?" He said, "Oh messenger of Allah, I
thought the person with you was Dea
Alcali in a private meeting for
something of your affairs." The
messenger of Allah said, "That was that
was
Gabriel. That was
Gabriel." And then you have these uh
these creepy ones. Hudifa answered, "The
people used to enter upon the prophet
whenever they wanted." So you could just
walk in and talk to Muhammad whenever
you wanted. Uh but then look what
happens. The prophet then prohibited
them from entering upon him while he was
in a meeting with Dal Kalby, right?
Whenever he's in a meeting with Dal
Kalby, you know, not to interrupt uh not
to interrupt Muhammad. And then you you
go down a little. So I'll go down to the
next paragraph. Hudhifa Hudifa added,
"One day I came to the prophet for some
matter hoping to meet him alone. When I
arrived at the door, I looked and found
a curtain covering the door. I raised it
and was about to enter. That's what we
were accustomed to do. Then I saw Da
sitting beside the prophet who was
sleeping and his head was on the lap of
Dia. Notice these separate
confirmations. So Muhammad liked to
sleep with his head on the lap of some
of some guy. So they see him. It's the
Al Kalby, but Muhammad's got a different
story. So this continues later on. See
down there at the bottom. Uh then Imam
Ali, so this is the third paragraph
there. Then Imam Ali asked me to enter.
So I entered and sat down. Soon after
that the prophet woke up and he smiled
when he saw the face of Imam Ali. Then
he told him, "Oh Abu Hassan, from whose
lap did you take my head?" Ali answered,
"From the lap of Dhil Kabi." Then the
prophet replied, "This was Gabriel." So
what did you tell him when you entered
and what did he tell you? What did what
did he tell you? What did you hear from
him? He didn't say, "Yeah, I'm DL KBY."
Did he? Uh so uh so guys uh notice the
notice the parallels notice the
parallels there everyone that you've got
Muhammad it really looks like something
is going on right really really sounds
like that looks like that sounds like
that and yet the explanation is no when
I'm behind the curtain with Dehal Kalby
that's really the angel Gabriel when you
see Dehal Kalby climbing out the window
in the middle of the night. That's
really the angel Gabriel. And then you
have this uh this other story about
Muhammad out in the desert and he's got
his buddy watching from behind the diddy
line and watching what's going on. And
then oh yeah, these are Jin. These are
Jin out there mounting Muhammad, not all
these guys. And oh, Muhammad's all
tuckered out again. And uh he has to lay
his he has to go to sleep with his head
on the guy's
lap. It's like weird. It's weird weird
parallels. in completely different in
completely different sources. So that
look
Oh, go ahead.
No, it just and and you're absolutely
right, but it gets worse and worse
because um
Oh, no. I Hey, what one second? I think
you're I think you're on a delay now
because it sounds like you're like 10
seconds behind whenever I whenever I say
something. You You want me to call back?
Should I call back? Should I call back?
If you can't If you can actually
Shutting down your com shutting down
your computer and restarting. I don't
know if you want to do that. That
usually fixes a delay problem. Uh if you
wanted to. Now you disappeared.
And all right, we got Raymond
back. There we go. Hey. Hey, David. Can
you see and hear me? Yep, I see and hear
you. Do you see and hear me at the same
time? I do. Great. Oh, good. Good. Yeah.
No lag anymore. No lag anymore. You're
good. Nice. Sorry about that. So, all I
was going to say is uh add on to what
you just said, which is that, you know,
what we're talking about is sort of a
sexual perverse homosexual encounter in
the night. And the thing is, you know,
you could you can kind of ignore that,
put that on the side if an aberration,
but it's not. As you were indicating, we
have a lot of weird sexual stories about
Muhammad that indicate homosexual
proclivities. Um, you already mentioned
that, you know, sucking on the tongues.
There's another one where all these
random guys would come up to Muhammad
and would get under his shirt or or
his and get excited and say, "Muhammad,
what's the one thing that we don't have
to ban or forbid?" And he would say,
"Water." But if you look into the
sources, water means male semen. So,
it's almost like a bunch of men were
rubbing up on him and uh you know, like
simulating sex. That's actually what in
in a hadith. I I was actually planning
on doing writing something about it or
doing a video. Maybe we can talk about
that if it's not well known already. So
my point is uh if it was just that
particular hadith of Muhammad having a
rendevu with you know these jin or el
zot or whatever the case may be we could
maybe give him the benefit of the doubt
but we've got other problematic sexual
especially homosexual
um hadith that go a long ways to sort of
confirm what we're discussing.
Yeah. you. So, we've got multiple
independent addestation of some weird
weird stuff going on with Muhammad and
it's kind of too much to cover up. It's
like, yeah, it's it's if you had one
thing and one weak hadith and so on and
it could be interpreted in multiple
ways, then you might say, okay, we'll
give the benefit of the doubt here. When
you find this stuff kind of all over the
place and in a bunch of Muslim sources
and it's in Sunni sources and Shia
sources and stuff, it's like explain
this. There's a pattern. There's a
pattern here. Pattern. There's
definitely definitely a pattern.
Um, pro but mo penis be a what's what's
wrong with the what's up with the weird
stuff, man? We know it's a weird topic.
Doesn't mean you have to post weird
weird comments. Dawa ain't recovering
from this. No, it's not. They're going
to they're going to try for a while and
they'll be able to get a lot of people
to think there's nothing here and we're
just going to keep uh we're going to
keep it doesn't mean ride. You have a
dirty mind. It means crowd.
I don't really get you. And you know I I
I said it in the video but maybe we
should take a second to discuss how okay
and here's what's really you know
interesting. If you do independent
research all right so we have the
hadith, we have the mutton, we have
what's being said in the Islamic uh
cannon, right? But then you can look at,
you know, these ethnographies written by
Arab literary sources which are not, you
know, Islamic per se. They're but but
they're Arabic. And all of a sudden you
find that alot these people have large
penises. All right? Now, this doesn't
come out in the hadith. All right? Uh
but rather it comes out in other
sources. So it really gets kind of
really problematic here. It's not just
tall. They're described tall, lean, as
in muscular, like very athletic. All
right, tall, athletic, black men,
basically with large fallacuses. That's
if you combine all the sources, that's
the image you get. And they meet
Muhammad for a pre-planned rendevous,
which all night long uh basically is
about them mounting him and riding him.
And then he returns in pain and
suffering. And then as I said in that
video, again I'm connecting. I'm not
saying this is necessarily what it
meant, but there is uh I I for maybe I'm
forgetting the source, but I think it's
in ali or or another source where you
know he has a tapier or an exagus about
Muhammad's description uh both in the
hadith and the Quran of paradise. And in
one of them he talks about how the
vagina never quits and the penis is
always erect. That phrase in Arabic is
the identical phrase of how the zuts
penis is described in literary sources.
Okay? In other words, that's the trope,
right? That's the trope, how they're
known. So, it's kind of interesting, you
know, and again, this is not my thought.
I'm trying to share with you what the
pmics are from the Arabic side. And
everyone is saying, "Oh, he really had a
great time that he went on as a personal
joke to himself to convince his
followers that that paradise is going to
be full of sex with these hard erect
penises. Little do they know, it doesn't
mean you are going to have it. It means
there's a guy there." Yeah. You're on
You're on the You're the recipient.
You're on the receiving end. You're on
the receiving end of a Right. Right.
Right. And again, I must say this isn't
my deduction. And this is what I
everyone is saying who knows Arabic and
who has studied this. So I'm just trying
to let I'm trying to even the playing
field so everyone knows what's going on.
Yep. And uh this is uh this is the new
thing for everyone to uh popularize. And
I like I like I like how they showed in
other various Quran translations where
that same Arabic word is it's always
ride. All right. And then and then one
said mounted. And then one said mounted
as you pointed out. Yeah. Yeah. Huh.
Interesting. Now they're going to change
all those translations to crowded.
And they actually do that, man. I don't
know how many times I've like cited
something, quoted it, and then I go back
to the link a year later and it's gone
and it's a whole different meaning, you
know? So, yeah, they they actually do
that. Oh, that's the thing. uh once we
start sharing it, that's why everyone
got to screenshot it now, then share the
link because two months from now, five
months from now, a year from now, all of
a sudden it'll change and the
translation will change or the source
won't be there anymore. All right, so
let's talk about something very
important. Um the the translation they
showed which had Arabic and English, I
believe it said, you know, that that
Abdullahbin Masoud saw them without they
were naked. And then it said, and I saw
it written in Arabic and English, um,
that he could not see their
genitalia. Now, in my original video, I
didn't mention that part. And there's a
reason because guess what? When I first
read this hadith almost 20 years ago, it
was not there. It didn't say anything
about like uh, you know, it said they
were naked, but it didn't say I did not
see their genitalia. All right? And I
think that's an interpolation that's
been added in later. This is sort of
damage control that has been introduced
by Alazar of let's you know try to
nullify this by saying hey there were no
p penises involved because he never saw
them but at the same time uh you know
you got to wonder
uh you you got to wonder can you hear me
something popped up anyway okay you have
to wonder uh it could mean something
else too um in other words by saying I
didn't see the penises so in the hadith
he says Muhammad made the line And then
he went he went as a stone throw which
can be pretty far for a seventh century
bedawin. All right. He even says a stone
throws or even further. All right. And
it's nighttime and they're dark skin so
it's going to be hard to see them. So
it's almost like it's all it could also
be interpreted as he's like trying to
see their penises and he can't. I was
trying I was trying to I was trying to
catch a peek but I couldn't. Dang it. I
Yeah, exactly. Cuz they're so far and
it's dark and they're dark and I was
trying to look at their penis. I didn't
see it. All right. So, so even that
doesn't really like help anything. But
it doesn't mean anything because some
people try to say, "Oh, he didn't see
the penis cuz they're jin." No, but the
Quran makes it clear the jin have
penises and they do have sex. So, that's
not what he means. I just wanted to
bring that up because that's another one
of the little um but also when I first
saw this hadith in Arabic and that guy
in the Library of Congress showed it to
me, it was not there. I honestly believe
now that with the with the advent of the
internet um Muslims are going back and
they're doctoring and changing hadiths
and they're adding things in even in the
most you know prestigious websites
universities they're doing it as a part
of damage control um to try to you know
you know cover up for what's going on.
Not surprising at all. That's what DA is
basically trying to cover things up. U
would love to see macho man Muhammad
Hijab be confronted with this. Yeah,
hijab would love this hadith. Um, hope
you go. I think this one is about you.
Oh, you don't know Muhammad
Hijab? No. Oh, he doesn't know anything
about what's going Yeah, guys, this he's
a reader. He's a reader. He's not uh
he's not been follow He doesn't follow
the YouTube drama and so on. But yeah,
he's a popular DA guy who has been in a
scandal recently and so on. Uh but um
please go and subscribe to Raymond
Ibrahim's channel. His videos are short
yet informative with the references also
provided. So you can write them down,
study and share them later. Without is
without without lies, Islam dies. Yeah.
Have links to Raymond's video on this
topic and to um and to his channel and
to the source that Giant Doc shared for
anyone wants to go around sharing that.
So share the video. Share the video.
Matter of fact, guys, here's how you do
it. Share Raymond's video and then when
people object, no, there's no source on
this, then share the link that Giant Doc
shared. Then you've got it. Uh, the
video thumbnail is wild. Dwood, you are
a genius. Yes, I know
this. Uh, could Muhammad have sensed
danger, told his companion to stay back
like a protective mother, and complied
with strangers to avoid being killed?
Uh, I've actually seen this. I've seen a
lot of people arguing like, you know,
this is Muhammad being altruistic. He he
he knew the sacrifice he had to make
with Alz and he told his friend, "Hey,
hang out here so you can be safe." Um,
you know, very pure altruism. So, hey,
have it. Yeah. Uh, only only issue,
guys. So, you know, you can interpret
things that way that Muhammad's
basically saying, "Take me, but leave
him alone." Uh, but it looks like it
really looks like this was all planned
and coordinated because he knows what's
about to happen when he's drawing this
line and so on. He's like, "Hey, just
make sure you stay behind this line.
This is the consent line. This is the
consent line. They'll know that you have
to consent. But see, no, here's an
important point. A lot of people, I
agree with you, but a lot of people say,
"Well, wait a minute. But why did the
line work?" Because according to hadith,
the line worked because uh Abdullahb
Masoud saw them, they came, they tried
to access him, he got freaked out and
sat down, and then according to the
hadith, they didn't reach him. So
apparently the line worked. So there's
another school of thought that there's
some sort of satanic magical element
involved here that Muhammad was, you
know, it would I I said I I suppose it
would comport with the genie idea. In
other words, there's these genies and
they're having some sort of uh you know
uh relations, but Muhammad is also
through magic protecting his friend for
whatever reason. Maybe it's not even a
good reason. I don't know. Uh I'm just
telling you a lot of the things that
I've been seeing uh that if anything
make it worse.
Yeah. So uh it makes it makes it makes
sense that this is something uh some
sort of magical line, but also that it's
a consent line. Like it's understood,
hey guys, if I bring someone to watch
and he's behind this line, he's there's
no access to to him. This is bad. But
Iben Massud, he doesn't he doesn't know.
He just sees the guys coming at him and
they're like, "Are is he going to invite
us past the line?" He's like, "I'm
sitting down. I don't know what these
guys are going to do." So, isn't it No,
I've never seen anyone notice that. Uh
I'm the first I'll take credit. I'm the
first one to notice that his reaction is
to sit down cuz a lot of I' I've watched
a I've watched a lot of PMICS, you know,
people who are attacking this and they
just go they go past it. Oh, he got
scared and he sat down. But to me, it's
kind of interesting. His first instinct
on being scared by these naked black men
who are cir, you know, circumnavigating
around him is to sit down. It wasn't to
run away. It wasn't to fight back. It
was to sit down. Doesn't that imply he's
trying to cover what he thinks they
want? It does look like if you saw a
bunch of guys coming at you worried
about like they're going to fight, you
wouldn't want to sit down. You'd want to
stand up and, you know, put your put
your guns up. But yeah, if you're like,
I'm going to cover I'm going to sit down
on my backside. Uh, that's what the
Arabic says. He got scared and sat down.
Uh, not to offend you, Ray, but do you
have any Lebanese in you at all? Not the
in like the zoot in Mo. I just mean
genetically. You are a spitting image of
a cousin of mine. Either way, God bless
you, bro.
Thank you. I don't know. I probably
should do a DNA test at some point, but
I've had a lot of people tell me I look
Lebanese, Syrian, etc. So, yeah. Uh,
easy choice to follow. the risen one
versus the ridden one. And we're proud
of
[Laughter]
that. That is true. I'm going to steal
that, too. Uh, thank you so much,
Raymond. Real gold. Oh, hi, David.
That's the other thing on the internet
now. They'll say nice about they'll say
something nice about someone and then
they'll say, "Oh, hi other person." Oh,
by the way,
uh, what is this? Grock says, "Hadith
uses the
word meaning to crowd." Wait, wait, I
see it. Uh
what? Oh, as okay, so that means to
crowd, but that's not the word I see.
No, that is the word that means to
crowd. And okay, so apparently I've dug
into this and later on a much later
hadith came out recounting the same
story and it uses that word. Okay, not
the original hadith. The original hadith
says ride, but a new hadith came out and
they do use is the which means the
crowd. Okay. Um, it sounds like, like I
said, it sounds like damage control.
Yeah. And, uh, if anyone wants to help
Grock, because again, guys, when these
uh AI things are doing searches, they're
also searching Muslim responses and
stuff like that. They can't tell the
difference between someone who's uh, you
know, biased in favor of Muhammad and so
on. So, you can actually probably help
out these AIs by saying, "Okay, what
about this hadith on this site right
here? What is what does this say?" and
get them to try and uh try and take that
into account. Best of deceivers. Yet
there are many other interpretations of
that term. I have been told I've
misunderstood that so many times. Well,
yeah, mocker would mean deception. But
if you if you want to translate it as uh
best of schemers or planners or plotters
and so on especially in the context
the best way to put macar for a western
audience especially those who are
familiar with mythology is uh a macar is
Loki a Loki figure you know that's
that's Allah he's Loki basically think
of all the trick trickster games that he
plays right he does say I' I've made
that comparison many times said said he
sounds more like Loki, then he sounds
like the god of the of the Bible. And so
yeah. Uh so Richard, if you want to
translate this as scheming, plotting,
planning, and so on.
Yeah, you can. Just keep in mind it's
the sort of scheming and plotting and
planning of like a trickster or a
deceiver. And so let's see. A caller
disconnected when CP showed him this
hadith. That's not surprising. So it's
talking about Christian Prince. So
people uh back out when people bring
this up. Hi. Hi, hell of a night from
Mo. Interested in Raymond's take on the
UK and advance of a ka fate uh advance
of ka fate generally. Have we been lied
to about crusades? Off topic. Sorry.
Well, you already touched on that a
little bit, but yeah, you've been lied
about the crusades. You've been lied
about everything. You've been lied about
history. All of history has been
completely, you know, a lot of people
talk about fake news, which I'm glad
they do because it's important. But like
I always point out, fake news, as
dangerous as it is, it's ephemeral. much
more dangerous is fake history. It's
much more dangerous as the fake history
they teach in, you know, kindergarten,
grade school, high school, college
because that creates paradigms and then
through those paradigms you see the
whole world, right? And um and yeah, it
was the Crusades is just one of many
examples of the sort of fake history
that has been foisted upon Western
peoples particularly in in intentionally
to to destroy them to be honest with you
to weaken them and emasculate them. Um
yeah, so I mean we that's a whole other
show. But yeah, yes short videos about
that would be good because that would be
timely because that's still uh that's
going on for a lot of people right now.
Um, uh, oh, now we got some comments
about the whole dehith and and and so,
by the way, before I forget, as you
know, there's all these hadiths of
Muhammad dressing as a woman, right?
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Dressing up. That's another that's
another that's another example of what I
was saying earlier that I'm sick of
giving the benefit of the doubt. You've
got all these hadiths which say that
Muhammad was in the garments of his
wives and so on. And Muslims will say,
"Oh, here it means blanket or here it
means house." They'll just make things
up. And it's like, and you say, "Well, I
mean, maybe, I don't know, or maybe it's
a euphemism for this or that." And you
say, "Maybe, but what's it actually say?
It says he was in the garments of his
wives." And or worse, why is there too
many one too many of these antidotes
going around all over the place? All
over the pattern. Yeah. Yeah. So guys,
no more giving the benefit of the doubt.
Muhammad was prancing around in his uh
in his child bride's nighty. And it was
all to uh it was all to get the
attention of the men of Zoot so they can
ride him all night long. That's what
we're going with. Got a couple more. Uh,
are atheists under the same unal alive
penalty as polytheist as only the people
of the book are able to be spared and
paid Jizia? Yeah, actual atheists
weren't really a thing back in that day.
It was monotheist and polytheist and so
on. Uh, but yeah, they would not be
under the uh they would not be under the
people of the book category as far as I
you you agree on that Raymond?
Yeah, I mean first the atheist is a
total like anacronism. Nothing like that
existed. But according to classical
jurian people the book were you know
Jews and Christians maybe Zorastrians
then they butchered the Hindus so they
killed a million of them and then they
decided to make money off of them rather
than kill them then they became people
of the book too. So
and uh Msh Cohen here uh who's Israeli
he says I became obsessed with Raymond
every uh ever since the last time you
guys had him on discussing is Islam at
war with the West. That video is also
one of my QRs. Uh Raymond, let me tell
you, Mash Mash here is funny. He's uh
he's in the military over there, but he
shares he shares uh QR codes that link
to our to link to our videos and so on.
uh he he actually tries to give
uh give the Arab Muslims information
about Christianity because he says he
wants them to convert out of Islam, but
he understands it's way more likely that
they'll convert to Christianity than
that they would convert to Judaism and
so on. So he uh he shares stuff it is.
Okay, cool. I appreciate that. That's
good. It's good work. Good stuff. That's
a topic we should talk about which is
you know the best uh strategy uh for
those who would convert Muslims out of
Islam. Is it to tell them uh this that
or the other thing including is Muhammad
a pervert or is Muhammad a non-existent
entity for example? Yeah that is and uh
there was actually a poll. So two things
one there was actually a poll on that.
Uh Muhammad Hijab, the guy we mentioned
a minute ago, the Dawa guy, he did a
poll several years ago and he asked
Muslims, he asked his Muslim fans, when
he said, "This is for those of you who
sometimes doubt your religion. When you
doubt your religion, when you doubt
whether it's true or not, what is the
cause of your doubts?" And he gave them
a bunch of options. The number one
answer, I think it was like 50% was
moral problems with Muhammad. Yeah, that
was the number one that was the number
one that was the number one thing. Yes,
I agree. And that's why um this is the
number one reason I have a problem with
the whole like Muhammad didn't exist
thing because it's kind of like it's
you're stepping out of the debate and
you're leaving the meaty area where you
can actually make an impact. Yeah. Which
is that, you know? Yeah. And so I'm all
I'm all in favor of uh like Robert
Spencer and Jay Smith pushing that and
seeing, you know, basically telling
Muslims, hey, why don't you defend your
prophet and show us that he at least
existed. This is how unreliable we think
your sources are. With that
said, I've heard from a ton of
ex-Muslims. I don't recall hearing from
an ex-Muslim who was persuaded by that
and left Islam because he thought, "Oh,
no, no, I can think of one. Muhammad
Sven Kish, to be fair, a German a German
guy who was a German scholar of Islamic
studies who was a convert to Islam and
he was eventually challenged. He was
said, "Hey, all these uh all these
um principles that you apply when you're
examining the Christian sources, these
skeptical methods that you apply when
you're examining the Christian sources,
why don't you apply those to Islam and
see what happens?" And he did. And he
con he left Islam and said, "I don't
even think Muhammad ever existed." Uh so
that's why David, you're talking about a
German guy. That's not a Muslim. Yeah.
Come on, man. I'm talking about a
Muslim. a real Muslim, not a German
convert. Yeah. So, as far as uh using
this for uh using this in in PMIC that
Muhammad didn't exist, it's kind of new.
So, we haven't Let's save that for a
Let's save that for a nice uh nice long
thing. Yeah. Yeah, we can. Uh um you got
to fight fire with fire. Now, I've been
watching this. I've been following this
for almost 20 years, especially in
Arabic satellite stations. And this is
the most powerful thing is when people
when here's the thing. When I say,
"Look, I agree with what you tell me.
Okay, Muhammad said this, the hadith
says it. Muhammad said that in the
Quran, whatever." Right? If I do that,
I'm playing their game. And then I point
out, look, but he also got mounted. Help
me out here. Right? But if I'm doing the
he didn't exist, you know, this whole
mounting thing doesn't even count. We we
can't even talk about this because he
didn't exist. Right? Uh so you see, it's
it's it's much different. Anyway,
um Dawoud and Raymond, I did not know
what type of hole I was getting into
today with this stream. Thank you. Uh no
pun intended. Yeah, no pun here. What
does that line that says that Muhammad
began to recite to them after they ride
him? What does that line that says that
Muhammad began to recite to them after
they ride him? Yeah. So that would
either be something that's added that
Muhammad is uh uh like if it's jin or
something like that then he's trying to
show them or uh no no what it says what
it says in one of the Arabic narrations
is that so some of them says uh you know
I saw the people who look like elut
naked tall whatever lean and they went
and started to write Muhammad and then
some say the same thing but then they
say and while they were writing him he
started reciting the Quran to them which
I mean on on the one hand may look like
a pious sort of effort on the other hand
may may look like a total mockery of his
own religion uh like he's mocking the
whole thing because he's engaged in that
and he's sitting there reciting the
Quran. So, I don't know. I'm just saying
it doesn't it's something that is in
certain narrations and uh you know and
texts. Uh but I don't know if it's just
like when they say it's the gin. I don't
know if that makes it better. It makes
it possibly worse.
Yeah. Let Justin know. Would Raymond do
a cra would Raymond do a class for
Hillsdale or Peterson? I'm guessing you
would. I know Hillsdale is a college. I
don't know what what Peterson that is.
That's probably Jordan Peterson um for
his stuff. But you seem pretty open if
people want to want you to do something,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sure. Sure. Yeah. So after Ramadan, do
we say he has ridden? Yeah. You don't
say he has risen like we do after
Easter. You say he was r He was
ridden. And Shane here says got two
more. Says they stop listening when you
bring up Muhammad. I'm who stops
listening. B. And Dwood. You were the
world's biggest Islamophobe until you
lost to Robert Spencer. Then he became
the biggest Islamophobe. I think Raymond
Ibrahim might have taken the title from
Robert Spencer. So, you were the biggest
world's biggest Islamophobe now. All
right. All right, Raymond, we got
through uh we got through all the super
chats and so on. Um, and it sounds like
we've got a couple more topics to cover
in the future as far as different
approaches and did Muhammad exist and so
on. Uh any final thoughts to share
before we close out on this topic?
No, I think the the the main uh
takeaways uh from what we discussed
today is that this hadith was and is
considered uh sah authentic and that
when they tell you it's not that's uh
you know they're taking some liberties.
two um you know they're apologetic which
is oh it's not people it's jin does not
help matters because jin have sex and
jin possess and the word for uh
copulating and the word for possess is
the word in the hadith they rode him um
so I think uh uh you know Muslims so
their best response is oh it's a fake
hadith ignore it but like I said most of
them don't even do that because they try
to salvage it uh because it is a strong
hadith
um you know anyway so that my final
thoughts are that when it comes to that
but you know the the interesting thing
is I brought all this up if you look at
the video I made I've known about this
hadith and I've known a lot a lot of
negative hadiths and it's not my
intention to poke fun at Muhammad or
Muslims but I really brought it up
because of uh what we'll talk about
eventually which is to show that the
hadith should not really be dismissed as
just fabrications in in many ways
indirectly
uh they actually like you were saying
you know about the authent you know the
chains and all that in many ways they
actually shed light on the reality of
who Muhammad was uh so I think that's
another uh really important avenue of
discussion down the down the down the
road no pun intended yeah okay and uh so
Dean responds and everyone else who's
watching right now uh I don't know what
I don't know how Dean responds is
responding to this if he's saying no
that's not what it meant it meant Jin
and they were just crowding around him.
If he's going that that direction or if
he's going in the direction of this is a
weak hadith, what are you doing quoting
a weak hadith? Um Dean responds just uh
tying all of this
together. You're in trouble either way
because you either uh you either grant
these sources or you think that Muslims
had some sort of reliable historical
methodology and that they were
preserving information accurately. In
which case, why do you have this source
here? And why do you have this story
about Muhammad being ridden by the uh
dark well-endowed men of Alzot out in
the desert all night long till he comes
back and in pain and collapsing on his
uh buddy's lap and so on. Well, you got
these and Dehal Kali and all these
really creepy stories about Muhammad. Or
or you can go the skeptical route. No,
this was just made up. And problem is
the more the more stories you have to
put in the put in the oh no we just made
those up and that's how they ended up in
all our books. Uh the more times you
have to do that the more you're actually
helping the skeptics about your sources
the more you're helping the Robert
Spencers and the J Smiths cast doubt on
your sources because you're basically
saying oh you know no our sources are
just filled with lies that people made
up and it's okay. So they they say ended
up in in like Muslim Ahmed and so on.
All these unreliable sources. So these
guys just didn't know how to do history,
did they? So okay, great. Great. Keep
keep going with that. And then don't
tell us anything about your prophet
because we're going to have to conclude
that your your method of preserving
information about him was complete
garbage. If we can't trust the most
embarrassing
stuff, we we're not going to trust the
good stuff because the good stuff is way
more likely to be fabricated than the
embarrassing stuff. So if we can't even
trust the embarrassing stuff, don't tell
us about the good stuff. if we're not
interested. And uh three lucky dogs said
David Wood and Raymond crushed Islam
tonight. Not of course the way the men
of Alz crushed Muhammad, but uh thank
you. And uh again, everyone, be sure to
uh check out Raymond's channel. He's got
he's got lots of videos out there,
especially on uh historical topics. And
uh the link to his video that you should
share. Definitely want to share this
video everywhere.
And again, you've got the link to giant
doc who shared the source. So share the
video and then when they say, "Nope,
this is all made up." Share the source.
It's got it right there on the screen
and popularize this. Spread it all over
the
place and we'll see what happens. But
it's not going to work out well for
Islam. All right, everyone. Thanks to uh
Giant Doc and Raymond for joining us.
And thanks everyone for watching. We'll
catch you next time.